peu
[Musique]
dites de versailles mystérieux par rené
à l'eau d'un collection des guides noir
chez choo comment avez vous abordé
versailles dessus alors on peut parler
d'abord d'abordage même oui le guide de
versailles telles que je les conçu dans
cette collection des ide noir que vous
connaissez exigeait une étude du mythe
de la monarchie absolue dont versailles
était l'expression monumentale et je me
suis surtout attaché à retrouver ce qui
n'avait pas été fait à ma connaissance
le plan politique le plan mytho
politique qui a précédé la construction
de versailles et qui en partent il
explique c'est pourquoi j'ai fait dans
une partie de ce guide line et tu que je
crois nouvelles sur les origines de
versailles et surtout sur les origines
du mythe solaire de la monarchie absolue
comme avez vous retrouvé l'auteur du
plan politique et qui est il
eh bien j'avais été frappée depuis
quelques années par le par un
rapprochement qui s'est imposé je crois
beaucoup d'érudits entre les idées
exposées par campanella un dominicain
dans un ouvrage utopique qui s'appelle
la cité du soleil j'avais été frappé par
les correspondances de ses idées avec la
conception d'une monarchie gallicane qui
avait été proposé précédemment par un
personnage très oublié mais quelle une
grande importance à son époque
guillaume postel en d'autres termes
entre
les théories de guillaume postel les
théories monarchique de campanella
j'ai essayé de retrouver le plan
politique qui a précédé versailles
nous sommes sous louis xiii en somme
sous louis xiii n'est ce pas une partie
de ce plan et met sous le règne de
charles neuf avec guillaume postel et ce
plan a été exposée de façon plus précise
dans les écrits de campanella
j'ai retrouvé en effet un texte
important une dédicace d'un ouvrage de
campanella au cardinal de richelieu dans
lequel ce dominicain calabrais dit au
cardinal la cité du soleil par mois ont
su par toi réaliser
quels étaient les rapports et je lui
avais lu ce livre bien c'est des
rapports plus étroits sont des rapports
plus étroits campanella dont la vie est
un roman d'aventurés extraordinaires
puisque ce dominicain avait organisé une
révolution contre la domination
espagnole avait été incarcéré à naples
torturé il y avait passé près de 18 ans
je crois dans les cachots de naples
campanella dans ces cachots avait écrit
un traité important qui s'appelle le
traité des nations dans lequel ils
pensaient que la monarchie catholique
c'est la monarchie universelle devait
être confiée au roi de france et ses
idées de campanella art et était connu
en italie par notre ambassadeur à rome
et aussi par un personnage qui est
devenu d'ailleurs le bibliothécaire de
colbert gabriel naudé et je pense que
c'est ainsi que richelieu été informé de
l'intérêt politique représentait les
idées campanella et ses idées politiques
confiant à la france la monarchie
universelle s'accordait d'ailleurs avec
la tendance hispanophone du pape urbain
c'est pourquoi campanella a été en
quelque sorte pris en charge par
l'ambassade
de france et il n'était plus en prison
il a été libéré en feintant on l'est on
lui a permis grâce à cette protection
l'ambassadeur de passer clandestinement
la frontière et il a été hébergé ex chez
l'érudit peiresc et ensuite il est à
paris où il est mort quelques années
plus tard après avoir participé au
conseil royal en ce qui concerne les
affaires d'italie et d'espagne et le
point très curieux de l'activité de
campanella a été la prédiction faite par
campanella au moment de la naissance de
louis xiv richelieu avait demandé
accompagner la était non seulement un
théoricien politique mais aussi un
astrologue comme beaucoup de savants
l'été à cette époque campanella a
calculé l'horoscope de louis xiv et il a
dit dans un texte qui a été conservée
que cet enfant était prédestinée à
réaliser la monarchie solaire que
lui-même avec onction
alors il m'a semblé intéressant de
rappeler ces rumeurs visionnaire de puy
guillaume postel jusqu'à campanella de
façon à faire comprendre que versailles
n'est pas surgir de la tête du jupiter
toute armée il ya eu un plan une
planification versailles est devenue le
centre du royaume à partir de 782
vraiment on ne peut pas imaginer d'un
simple nous simple passion pour la
chasse suffisent à expliquer versailles
il ya eu un plan politique et c'est ce
plan politique que j'ai ce qu'est le
trouver en proposant une notion je crois
nouvelle celle de la mito politique
c'est-à-dire ce désir collectif de
l'inconscient collectif qui prépare une
politique qui la soutient avant que
cette politique de ce manifeste est de
ce point de vue j'ai étudié versailles
en essayant d'interpréter le monument
après le révérend père guillou qui
l'avait déjà fait dans un ouvrage qui
s'appelle versailles palais du soleil
j'ai essayé d'étudier versailles en
montrant que c'était un manifeste
monumentale de la monarchie absolue et
se manifeste repose sur une idée
mythique
c'est une image monumentale de l'homme
idéalisé par le mythe de la monarchie
absolue
l'homme le rayon solaire le roi est ce
que vu d'avion si je puis dire ça
devient plus visible est ce qu'on est
plan politique apparaissent et bien
c'est très que à l'ensemble c'est très
curieux parce que j'ai vu je me
photographie aérienne de verser de
regarder également au niveau allemand
croit le le plan général et cela c'est
le christ roi qui a été qui a été en
quelque sorte confondu avec l'idée de
celui qui devait réaliser la monarchie
universelle de la contre-réforme peut
donner l'exemple de la nef aussi été
pris de malaise
oui je dis que le mythe explique
beaucoup de choses parce que dans les
écrits de guillaume postel auquel je
fais je faisais allusion tout à l'heure
il y à cette idée mythique très curieuse
qu'on trouve d'ailleurs signalé par
d'autres auteurs que la monarchie
absolue doit revenir à la monarchie
gallicane comme l'appelle postel parce
que l'on bat france est le descendant de
noé et jusqu'à présent vous savez pas
très bien pourquoi la messe est partie
essentielle du couvert royal était
entouré d'un tel respect mais grâce à
l'analyse de celui qu'on le trouve très
simplement c'est que la nef et l'image
de l'arche et par conséquent elle est
enterrée la présence symbolique de
l'ancêtre mythique de la royauté et je
pense qu'il faut comprendre qu'au xviie
siècle comme vous
huitième siècle des idées qui nous
paraissent maintenant vraiment des
mirages des illusions était encore très
active très avaient beaucoup
d'importance par exemple le xviie siècle
n'a pas été comme on le croit
généralement l'âge du rationalisme
cartésien
c'est ainsi avec le marquée par des
procès de sorcellerie par des affaires
assez compliqué il ya eu des études
récentes sur les dossiers de police du
dix septième siècle donc s'aperçoit que
le nombre d'affaires suspecte a été
peut-être plus considérable pour siècle
précédent dans le domaine
est-ce que l'ensemble de ces guides peut
être défini de la même façon à quelques
détails près je prends la tension tht
l'intention présente une certaine unité
et je vous remercie juste ailleurs
d'ailleurs le pouvoir m'expliquer à ce
propos parce que je voudrais bien que
l'on comprenne justement l'intention de
cette collection
erin est en grande partie des travaux de
monsieur harvey d'hôtes en ville sur la
mythologie française et monsieur repart
bull a publié récemment un autre livre
qui s'appelle la france mythologique
dans lequel il attire l'attention sur un
fait d'une importance insoupçonnée nous
étudions la mythologie assyrienne nous
étudions la mythologie aztèque
mais finalement nous sommes très
ignorants de notre propre mythologie et
il nous a paru intéressant de faire dans
une collection de guides un recueil de
documents sur notre inconscient
collectif en quelque sorte sur toutes
ces légendes sur toutes ces
superstitions qui finalement nous
permettent de descendre dans les
profondeurs de l'âme française
dans l'est au moins dans les profondeurs
de ses désirs je pense que par exemple
des ouvrages comme le lit de la provence
le guide de la bretagne apporte beaucoup
à la compréhension profonde des
différences ils sont des dossiers mais
cela ce sont des dossiers et j'ai été
dans mon guide de versailles
particulièrement désireux de montrer que
cette implication du mythe exige non
seulement à recensement de ces de ces
légendes des superstitions ses coutumes
locales mais aussi une compréhension
plus profonde que celle de l'historien
rationaliste
en effet pour moi il ya trois façons de
comprendre l'histoire l'une qui consiste
à décrire simplement des événements et
des personnages comme au théâtre
quand on voit les acteurs et on
enregistre les répliques l'autre façon
d'écrire l'histoire qui consiste à dire
au fond l'histoire ce sont les coulisses
ce sont les ressorts économiques de sont
les ressorts technique
c'est cette conception qu'on a surtout
développé à notre époque et il y a quand
même une troisième façon d'écrire
l'histoire qui est d'essayer de
comprendre la relation psychologique
entre les acteurs et les spectateurs
n'est ce pas les acteurs quand même
reflète les désirs des spectateurs
pourquoi les spectateurs applaudissent
style pourquoi siffle t-il à d'autres
moments c'est qu'il y a réellement une
description psychologique
une recherche de l'inconscient collectif
qui explique toute une partie de
l'histoire qui à ma connaissance n'a pas
des techs blanc commandé la laddh la
devise de ces guides c'est pourquoi si
feuilleton pourquoi bloody temps
pourquoi des iut
[Musique]